welcome everyone to the data science hangout and
i know most people who are on today they've you've
been here before so you kind of know the drill but
for anyone who's new today this is an open space
for current and aspiring data science leaders
to connect and just chat about some of the
more human-centric questions around data
science leadership but also to focus on
questions that are most important to you all so
there's three ways that you can ask questions
you could just jump in live put questions in
the chat or we also do have a slido link where
you can ask anonymous questions too and rob will
share that link in the chat in just a moment here
but just a quick note that the session will be
recorded and shared up to youtube so just want to
make you aware of that if you're jumping in live
but again feel free to ask questions anonymously
too i'm so happy to be joined by my co-host for
today zach garland manager of econometrics and
data science at mastercard and zach i'd love to
just have you introduce yourself and maybe share
a bit about the work that you're doing on your
team today yeah no absolutely um hi everyone
my name is zach garland um i'm part of the
economics institute of mastercard and i i think
the easiest way to kind of summarize what we do
we like building cool [ __ ] um and all you know
i'll try to to not cuss but i wanted to make this
feel very open um i'm obviously not in a suit or
you know anything special i'm kind
of in you know what i'm in every day
um and so yeah it you know open questions feel
free to ask anything um yeah excited to be here
awesome so while we're waiting for
a few questions to come in as well
zach i think one of the things that was really
interesting to me chatting with you this week is
um really about the ways that you go you make
people interested in data and then the work that
you're doing on your team i think it'd be cool
to just maybe share a few examples of some of the
stuff that you're working on yeah no absolutely um
so i guess there's there's a lot of broad things
that data science covers um i think that we try to
figure out how to approach it really holistically
um you know from the point that you pull the data
to transforming the data or visualizing it and
you know i guess some simple plots and then how
does that eventually make its way to either a
product or um an output like a report and so
you know one of the ways that we're constantly
communicating is is really a public report um and
then we have kind of our client presentations or
um i guess you could say stakeholder presentations
where that's really the summarized view um and
in general i mean i think that we always
try to summarize you know big topics um in
a way that everyone can consume and that's my dog
winston by the way um for anyone that was curious
i love the dog running up in the background
yeah no he's he's the he's the day one homie
but um yeah and and you know i think that we we
try to find ways to explain it to a sixth grader
right like i think within data science you can
get very very in the weeds and it's all super
exciting for people that understand it but for
someone that's not familiar with data science or
how to interpret data you almost have
to find a way to really explain it or
find a way to summarize your ideas and so i
think that that's always been kind of a driving
factor for us and even you know we have we have
this framework where it's what am i looking at
and why does it matter and it's it's a very you
know two very simple questions but i think it
you know it gets to the heart of what you're
trying to do which is you know show something
and then why does that matter um and so
yeah that that's kind of a side comment but
awesome and kind of going on on that path as
well i see kevin you just asked a question
um around the late what's your latest
fun project that you've worked on yeah so
um i would say that it's it was a very fun project
but it was very very um work intensive so we're
we're coming out with a small business report and
the fun thing at least from my perspective i like
developing um i like code and i've been learning
javascript um trying to find more ways to use it
and so from my perspective the most exciting
or fun thing was i finally found a way to have
um basically a static rendered or
markdown map show all of these individual
city level leaflet maps um and so i'm talking in r
but um i think that's probably acceptable here but
um it was super fun for me to figure that
out and find a way to make it work um and
yeah i think it's it's a very visually appealing
report and so i think we're releasing it uh next
tuesday and i i can send out a link um to that
but um there is just a general you know mastercard
services.com economics institute um where
you can find like most of our public reports
and so that's that's a really good place to
at least kind of see what's accessible or
out in the public you know view and then outside
of that you know i would say that we're constantly
trying to focus on the business or trying
to understand where does this fit in the big
picture um how do we provide value to our clients
how do we provide value to our stakeholders
um and so those are always you know really
exciting those are more thought processes or
how do we you know think about this how do we
think about it differently what's bad what's good
you know so on and so forth so yeah one question
that i had for you and if anybody else has
other questions you want to ask live feel free to
jump in uh but i know mastercard being such a huge
company i was curious how you go about like
showing the value of open source and explaining
to maybe other stakeholders um the importance
of open source yeah no absolutely um so i think
when i think about open source i mean i'm in love
with open source um i think there's a lot of value
in sharing code and using code debugging
code um and having that all available and so
i mean one of the reasons why i'm such a our
studio supporter advocate is all of the packages
were built for some reason and they all more or
less speak together um they talk to each other
they have the ability to integrate functions with
you know one another and i think when you when
you start to scratch um which is really what you
know i joined shortly after the group was started
and there wasn't you know any paid pathway or any
you know determined this is what we have to do
and so when you start from scratch like that
it offers the ability to really design a full
framework or a entire system or an entire portal
um however you want to kind of describe it but
it it makes it interesting when you start doing
that to see how much you're leveraging open
source because it's probably a lot um and
that's that's always been kind of my view
that many companies are seeing the end result
of open source but i think the conversation
really has started to turn more towards you
know how do we start to be an active member
how do we start to think
about what we need to keep
very secure and um i guess behind some form of
authentication and then how do we also start to
generate new ideas with open source or how do
we start to partner with them to take on a big
project or if we have an idea you know how do
we start to think about what can be open source
versus what couldn't be um and i think the easiest
like intro to that is talking through inner source
so how do we share within the company first
um how do we start to approach you know
broad frameworks or you know building out all
of these different components and so i think
the inner source conversation is is
an easier one to approach or get into
but i think eventually that that really
transitions into how do we talk about open
source how do we you know view open source um
and how do we really collaborate and contribute
that's one of the first times i
myself have heard the like inner
inner source and open source conversation and
was just curious if others from the group as well
have talked about it that way or thought
about it that way with leadership
we've talked about it and implemented
certain things but i like having the
term that specifically identifies what you're
saying i'm going to totally take your term
sure for what it's worth it's not my term i don't
remember where i read it but i was like yes that's
exactly like um yeah i i'm trying to thank
you for sharing it of course yeah i like that
um daniel i see that you asked a question in the
chat and i wanted to pass the mic over to you to
have you ask that live sure sure um so basically
my question was just if you could talk a little
bit about kind of like the idea generation and
idea refinement process to kind of get to things
that you actually want your team to work on in
the sense that like i think a common uh dilemma
is that like the i just use business it's kind
of like the non-tech folks but like the business
folks kind of know a lot about their individual
problem areas but don't know about the tech side
and the tech side obviously knows sex side but
at the business side and so you can get ideas
from either or uh but like how you go about
kind of getting this from the larger number
of like potential projects to the ones that
like you actually have your team working on
yeah no i i think that that's a great question
um i would say that our team is constantly
generating ideas and so i would say that we have
a very almost open board when it comes to new
ideas or doing new things and i think we're very
quick to drop something that you know we thought
was interesting but then turns out it would take
too much or the data would be too hard to pull
or there's some you know something that causes
us to kind of change paths and then when we find
something that's that's really good i would say
that we invest in it and we double down on it
and i i like that approach because it's it's
a it's almost an open you know collaboration
between teams like how do we come up with the best
ideas how do we move on from bad ideas quickly
and then how do we really hone in on what's good
um and so i think it works well you know the
the hard part about it is sometimes managing a
lot of things going on at once um i think for
anyone that codes or is in data science they
know how intense some of the projects can get
and so i think managing expectations and trying
to communicate you know requirements or needs is
super important um but generally you know if
if you have good ideas or you can constantly
come up with new ones and and find a way to really
communicate them um it makes for a fun environment
can i just ask one quick follow-up to
that uh based on part of what you were
what you were saying uh like i like the idea
of kind of being able to pivot quickly uh in
doubling down on kind of like the the
uh the things that are worth doubling
down on do you ever get pushed back when
you're dropping some of the stuff that is
no longer seen as important and kind of like
how do you deal with that yeah um i mean there's
there's always going to be pushback from some area
right where there's so many people to please and
there's so much that that you know is in the realm
of possibilities or opportunities and you know i
think managing expectations and really just trying
to communicate is super super important um and you
know i think that that's that's where sometimes
you get into trouble is not communicating needs
or um not you know finding a way to really
communicate so that someone else has
understanding um and yeah so i i mean the the
short answer is there's no perfect solution and
there's always going to be someone that that
wants to go one way and you want the other
but the more that you can kind of be confident in
what you're you're planning to do or want to do
and then really just doing it it makes it a lot
easier to kind of come back with well we didn't
we didn't get this done but here's what we got
done um and you know things like that are helpful
do you have any tips on
communicating those expectations
i almost want to say i'll let you know when i
find them but um i i would say you know really
just going back to kind of the how do we explain
this to someone that doesn't understand it and the
best way to do that in my opinion is kind of treat
it like you're explaining it to a six-year-old
how do you explain the big picture what's the
goal why does it matter what does it require
and not getting too in the weeds of
of the details i guess not i think any time that
you approach data science it you're always going
to find people that really don't understand it
or don't understand what's involved with the code
or how it needs to scale and so the
more that you can kind of bring it to
a mutual understanding or common ground that makes
it easier but it's certainly a topic that i think
over time will get better i think data fluency
is something that will improve in the future
i think more more and more people will
code um i would love to see it um i guess
from my perspective i'm a self-taught uh coder
and so i think there's so much great material
out in open source whether that's books or
videos webinars um packages all of it really
comes together to create a more open environment
where that understanding starts to bridge but i
think we're kind of early in the game like i think
that data science is relatively new even though
it's super super old but the concept of you know
how much data is becoming available and how much
data is being generated really opens up that door
for for people to start having that conversation
thank you tatiana i see you asked
a question in the chat around
a framework would you want to
introduce yourself and jump in and
ask that question sure well first of all thank
you so much for organizing this is this is great
uh thanks zachary for sharing your knowledge so
generously this appreciated i i got some online
certifications in data science obviously i'm not
a super big expert in a subject and i'm willing
to learn i'm currently working as a business
intelligence analyst and i have a question
about frameworks that you use when approaching
a new topic from how you manage expectations
to how you decide which project in your words is
good or bad do you have specific apis that you go
to to measure your new project against do you
have specific steps that you go from um i don't
know from uh deciding on whether or not to take
it on to um measuring which model it's best to use
to maybe setting adoption targets and making sure
that the data is validated and the users are using
it so any tips that you can give regarding that
yeah no i i think that that's a great question
um and so i guess the the way that i've approached
projects has always been and and not always
um i wish that i had approached projects you know
always this way but i always start with a package
um and the first package that i started at the
economics institute was this package called ei
tools and it's it's a conglomerate of many things
in the tidy verse or and use this for anyone
that's familiar with that but i always start with
a package so anytime i have a new idea i build out
you know a simple package and then store it you
know everything that's related to that inside
of that package and i think what that offers the
opportunity to do is to really have organization
around all the things going on so if an idea gets
dropped it's not a big deal it's still there um
but at least it's it's getting to the right
framework or starting to be in the right
form before you really pursue something and so i
guess by way of example when i was getting started
um i built out this this big application and it
had a ton of functionality um and it was more or
less just me learning um but i didn't build it in
a package you know files were were hard referenced
and there was just a million things that you
know could have been improved if i had come up
with kind of that that initial package structure
um and so i think the more that you kind of um
dive into projects you start to kind of find a
flow and i think the package structure really
works well for me um and i i would say it's it's
not an easy thing to get through um none of it's
easy and it all takes a lot of time and and
learning you know trying failing um all things
that i've i've done and so um yeah i would say
as long as you have kind of a positive mindset
about it and try to to get things organized um the
better off you'll be and then in terms of you know
um model performance and how to think about all
that i think it's such a big topic that there's
no perfect answer um i think the more that you can
focus on kind of the end output for what the value
is of what you're trying to do the better and
then the the rest of it is kind of just details
thank you zach i see there's a lot of chat
uh conversation going on in the chat around
a specific question too so hugh i'd love
to have you ask your questions in life
sure um and thank you uh septori and i'm
bruno those are really good thoughts uh
things i hadn't considered before um uh i'm
also mostly self-taught it's nice to hear that
i'm not alone um but one of the things that i
know i personally struggle with is every time i
pick up a new resource or uh any kind of training
i'm i'm finding things that i feel like i should
have known early on or you know blind spots
in my knowledge do you have any strategies for
kind of proactively seeking those out
yeah so um i you know i think it's
it's a very individual question where i think
there's plenty of ways that people can learn um
for me i love books um and i have too many
that i haven't read um too many that i buy
and i'm like i'm gonna read and then i just
don't um but what i like about books is
if you start from the very top and you finish it
you have so much knowledge that that author had
um and so a great example is just the data science
for our book um it took me a long time to really
get through the entire book go through all the
exercises and to really understand the concepts um
but once i felt like i had really mastered all the
concepts or really read through all the chapters
i felt like i had almost a framework um and
same thing with the r packages book or you know
the mastering shiny book um and there's there's
actually this book that's called the big book of r
um and it's basically just links to books on
different topics or different ideas different
approaches or things that you could learn and so i
always think that that's a really great reference
videos are super helpful at least for me but
i mean anything you know training courses
um or you know in-person meetups or and i know
we're we're kind of still on covet so maybe
not in-person meetups but um things like this you
know how do you think about new ideas or get um
get someone else to share ideas on code or data
science modeling you know all of these different
things that that are available so yeah i i would
say that um the the fear of not knowing what you
should have known that that's always present like
i know that there's a million things i don't know
um but i do know that there's ways to find
it um or to learn it and so as long as you
kind of have a learning mindset then you know
it's always the the best place to start thank
you i appreciate that so yeah your stack of unread
books sounds like you're describing my nightstand
i have a coffee table and i think sometimes um
when when people come over and you know they'll
see it like right now uh the book that i haven't
gotten all the way through would love to is
this book called full stack um d3 and
it's this gorgeous book um gorgeous cover
and it's just this massive textbook and i
think people always come in and they're like
you're not reading this and i'm like yeah no i'm
not like but i'm trying to you know i'm trying to
so the question is are your is your nightstand
and coffee table made of these books or the books
i um i do like woodworking so i i actually
built like my record soon but um haven't
made anything out of books um that's a that's a
new idea so maybe i'll have to think about that
i see there's a few helpful books that people
are sharing in the chat window as well so
feel free to share any others
there or anyone listening in too
there's a few anonymous questions coming in too
so i want to make sure i ask a few of those um
and the first one was how do you communicate
your results do you use the open source solution
enterprise cloud or something else yeah so i
think that that's a great a great question um
so i think when you're developing on your own
you have open source to leverage and really
constantly evolving technology and
i think when you're in a company the
the thing that i didn't understand
before was really you know
there are predetermined systems or predetermined
um technology solutions that you kind of have to
start with where you know even if there's a better
solution out there um what's available is kind of
what you get and so i think there's there's almost
this balance between what do we have access to
today and what do we really want to have access
to tomorrow um you know and how do we start to
communicate where these different technologies
come into place or what that would enable um
you to do and i think you know developing
on your own i i would always urge people to
to constantly push new technologies and to find
ways to to really utilize them um and i actually
i saw this pdf where it went over the data
landscape or um all of the different technologies
that are going on in the world and there's so
much um and so i think opportunity is there and
you just have to find out how do we kind of hand
pick um what's really going to work for our group
or for the company um and then how do we start
to kind of pursue it um yeah hopefully that helps
following up on that question i guess if you
like find a technology that you want to pursue
what does that process look like for you or what
tips you have for someone who's trying to do that
yeah absolutely so i think that really gets to um
communicating with stakeholders right so finding
some way to use what you have access to today to
provide value and then coming back and saying i
know that you love this but here's what we
could do with this and i think it's really
you know finding ways to produce something that
people really understand and view as valuable and
then showing them how they that new technologies
or additional systems could really enhance that
or improve it scale it and just showing them
kind of what that next step might look like
but really just opening up the conversation
you know finding ways to ask questions
or to say here's something i
think would be super valuable
how should we approach that um because
i think that that's also something that
people should be comfortable with is you're
not always going to know how to do something
like that or how to really start asking those
questions and so i think you know just starting
with hey here's something i'm thinking through
here's why i think that might be valuable you
know how should we think about that or how could
we approach that is always super super helpful
cool thank you bruno i see you had asked
a question earlier around the data that
zach works with would you want to ask that
question live yeah sure all right thanks for me
i think you just muted yourself on accident
sorry there you go hi how are you doing uh thanks
for uh doing this uh i was just wondering at the
mastercard scale uh like with many data scientists
how do you uh how do you process everything you
can use like you have access to so much data like
what what resources do you use what challenge
do you face uh processing all that information
yeah so you know i think that um that's a great
question um when it comes to data and even just
our group so our group is made up of economists
and data scientists and so even the economists
look at as much data as they possibly can we
were we were reviewing with a vendor you know
how many different series or how many different
things we look at over a given year and it's
it's a lot um so i think the more that you can
be curious about what's available or how do we
find ways to really leverage that or view it
visualize it model it um the better off you'll
be but there's there's certainly you know plenty
of challenges along the way to actually getting
data then going through a process of modeling or
coming up with summary statistics and then really
what's the end output how do we visualize
that how do we communicate it to others
and so i think the more that you you constantly
stay curious the better off you are but
there's there's certainly um plenty of
challenges that come up along the way so
maybe a bit related to this there was an
anonymous question that asked have you had any
issues with using large data sets in r um and do
you have any favorite packages to deal with that
yeah so um you know i think
i think when it comes to that
or works for just about anything at least from
what i've found um there's certainly times where
you're trying to do too much with it and it might
be slow but generally speaking you could load in
massive files and manipulate all of it
and then output it to some small table
i think that sql is kind of the the natural
progression to larger and larger data um that
could be you know a million different things or
you could view that in a million different ways
but um finding some way to store the data
and then to pull some level of calculation
um without pulling the full
thing that's kind of the
the best solution so db player um is kind of the
um the go to at least for me i i like writing
you know and are more than i like writing
sql um even though i do totally value sql um
and i think it's a valuable skill um i you
know i just love tidy verse and our packages
thank you so um saul i see you
just asked a question around
metrics for success do you want to
add a little bit of context there
i can just ask the question is what are metrics
that mastercard uses to measure success or impact
i think that's a that's a great question um
it's something that i i think about often
um i don't know that we have a perfect
solution for that um you know i think
if you are generating revenue that's a super
simple way to you know um kind of measure success
our group currently you know we we are pursuing um
that but when we got started you know that wasn't
part of what we were doing um and so i think
that that's really when it starts to get down to
you know how much are we
communicating with clients
how much are we communicating with stakeholders
are we helping them to do their jobs better
or to have a better understanding of you know
data or the macro view and you know are we
really enabling them to do better and so i think
there's there's plenty of opportunities to kind
of measure or to try and figure out you know
how do we view this as valuable um but i think
um those are kind of the the two avenues
that i would i would kind of identify
i know one of the examples you had shared
with me was on like travel and sharing some
of those insights i guess taking that like success
question a bit further like how would you measure
success for that project yeah so i i think
um very early on we kind of identified
core themes and so we started with this idea
of you know how do we come up with you know
six or seven themes that broadly we want to
cover or that we want to have a view on and then
how do we constantly kind of enhance it so if you
were to look at our first projects or our first
you know dashboards or reports um we took a view
or tried to come up with a view um and then we
constantly just made it better so i don't know
that we we had any measure of of success other
than you know people telling us that they liked
it they valued it you know they appreciated it um
but in terms of kind of measuring how how
well we're doing i think it's certainly an
area that um we could probably do some
more exploring or thinking through
thank you and i i just shared that link in
the chat if you want to check out some of
that work too um i see you asked a question in
the chat can i pass the mic over to you yeah
um uh thanks zach for uh for sharing a lot of
these insights um a lot of the discussion earlier
was around like um you know kind of uh coding and
things of that nature um how do you i guess how
do you ensure that like your team is all kind
of using is up to date basically like you know
a lot of people have different varying levels
of skill with regard to coding or data science
how do you guys kind of make sure that people
are kind of in sync yeah no i i think that that's
a great question um and even for you know data
scientists so like for me i'm very code first um
but a lot of people that we work with
or that are part of our group they work
within tableau um and so even with tableau you
know the the funny thing about it is there's
and i'm probably kind of getting sidetracked with
a different maybe i'll mention that after but um
there's no easy way to make sure that everyone's
on the same page or has the same code or has the
same understanding of code what's worked for us is
trying to figure out you know how do we leverage
each other's skills um regardless of technologies
and you know a great example is really tableau so
the economist will come up with these great
views or these great dashboards and then i
can take those and make them into code or
find ways to visualize them differently
put them into a public report um and so i think
it's it's really just gets down to communication
having an understanding of skills and then
trying you know along the way to teach each other
um and to learn um and so i guess the the side
uh portion that i was gonna go off into was uh
under the hood tableau is xml and so for a coder
like i love trying to parcel of it and trying to
understand like what can i pull out of this or
you know how do i pull this color palette or
um things that are kind of more nerdy um but
it's you know finding ways to do what you love
even though it might not be
with the tool you love or
the technology you know it's always
kind of the path that i've taken thanks
expanding on that a bit further i see there was
an anonymous question that says what are your
thoughts on the no code movement um in auto
ml yeah so i i think at the end of the day
there there is value in no
code and people that don't code
i guess from my perspective the reason why i
love coding is it offers unlimited possibilities
so i think that the main
difference for me has always been
if this solution doesn't do what i want it
to do is there any way that i can fix that or
am i kind of um set with what is available and so
for me i love developing new things or trying to
generate you know different ways that we could
do something and so that flexibility for me has
always been super important um but that being said
you know there's a lot of value like i always go
to tableau as a great example because dragging and
dropping and creating beautiful visualizations or
decks dashboards is super super valuable um and
yeah i you know i think both are super valuable
um i've just always been very code first
because i like developing and um yeah
thanks zach um one other anonymous question that
came in was how do you balance your passion and
personal interest and business requirements
when it comes to adopting tools and projects
yeah i you know i think that that's that's
another great question um it's not always easy
um and you know you you always have to find
ways to have some level of balance between both
um and a good example is so when i first started
we had you know we had to really come up with
a business plan and a way to communicate that
and we wanted to do something kind of crazy or
off the wall and so we used prezi and it was a
great you know it was a great presentation it
was very fun it was very interactive um and then
eventually i quoted you know an html presentation
but um i think there's always a balance of you
know figuring out like what do we really need
and is this the right solution and then at
some point the the hope is always that you
can really really leverage your skills because
you're starting to produce you know things that
always can answer questions or can always
satisfy some need um but that certainly takes
time and it and it certainly doesn't happen
you know overnight but um the more that you
have kind of your passion and your work the
better and i think the more that you kind of
push that agenda or trying to find ways to
do what you love um the better off you are
your answer and just mentioning like presenting
the business case was making me think of
something i had meant to ask earlier as
well but around the economics institute
in general could you explain a bit more about what
that is and how it serves as an innovation lab
yeah absolutely um so we're really a group
of you know economists and data scientists
and our job is to really come up
with great stories and great insights
and you know i think that we've always taken the
view of of trying to to view things differently
um trying to find the hidden story or the thing
that no one's else you know is looking at um and
i think that when we look at the group as a
whole what we're really talented at is constantly
being in communication with you know clients
stakeholders really understanding what what
challenges or things that they're going through
and then finding ways to really explain what's
going on how do they think about that um how do
they view it or come up with new ways to approach
it um and so i think you know the the group as
a whole is is made up of a lot of very curious
and hard-working individuals um and i think
that that that's really created kind of an
environment where you know we're we're
constantly just trying to find cool things to
to show or communicate and then you know how do
we help people to do what they do better and so
apologies if i'm pronouncing your name wrong that
you asked a question that follows this as well but
when you say like do really cool things or show
cool things with data what are some of the most
interesting insights that you've gotten so far
from projects you've worked on at mastercard
yeah um i i would say it's it for the
most part it's all pretty interesting
um sometimes you know as a data
scientist it's hard to keep up with
what all the different views are or all of the
interesting insights that the group generates as
a whole um i would say for me i i've always
enjoyed you know really finding ways to
visualize things so right now i'm i'm trying to
learn d3 because i just find it so cool um and
it's super difficult um and it's not you know
it's not coming easy but um you know i think even
within tableau you know we have an economist i
always look at her dashboards and i'm like wow
this is like this is so cool and you know
i think it's it's really just trying to
find things that are interesting
and that you would enjoy
or that you find cool and then you know
communicating it um but i guess like
i don't know if there's a specific example like
i i would say the small business report there's
things i find super cool in that um there within
the travel report you know there are things that
i i found super cool in that um but yeah i
don't know it's it's probably uh an answer
of there's so many uh things that are fun or cool
to look at it's probably hard to kind of pick one
in terms of the the small business report what
what is that show or what is that is that a
visualization that you produce yeah so you know
i think when when you look at our public reports
um and even just you know i can openly talk about
kind of what's under the hood so um our public
reports for the most part have always been built
with our markdown um and i think that we try to
push it to the limits of what that that can do um
but generally it's it's a very easy framework to
use um you can constantly improve it and so i
i think there's always this element of what it
started with was really you know analytics stuff
right where it's very analytics heavy there's um
there's a very s you know kind of standard view
of color um where we started to transition to more
elegance and design um how do we create something
that people are are going to find visually
appealing um and so i i think that that's that's
probably like my side gig is a you know design um
i enjoy it and um i think that you know we we
bring in a lot of visualizations that weren't
built with r um so things like video or pictures
or um you know graphics that are animated um
and so i think it's just finding cool ways to show
what you're trying to think through or trying to
communicate um but i certainly kind of love when
my graphics make the end cut as well so yeah
awesome thank you just scrolling through
to make sure i didn't miss questions from
earlier um i see saul maybe had dropped off but
asked the question earlier on how would you advise
people to learn topics like econometrics
having a limited statistics background
that's a very good question um
so what i've you know the one thing i realized
about economics is i thought i had some level of
background in it um and then you meet a bunch of
smart economists and you realize you really don't
know much um and so i think at the end of the
day there's so much that you can always learn
um econometrics is is not super
straightforward is is probably the blunt answer
um it's it's complex there's lots
of things that need to be considered
or treated for um and i think that i'm constantly
learning about it um or trying to understand it um
but i i don't know that i have any tips
for here's great references or you know
a lot of the stuff i i've kind of learned
on the job um and over time and so yeah
thank you going back to that last question a
little bit i know you said you like design and
it's great when sometimes your visualizations are
the ones put out there uh how do you kind of test
design and and think about like what appeals to
to people and what's going to maybe get catch
people's attention the most yeah um i think just
trying new things is is kind of the fun part about
design is um there's there's always some way that
you could show it differently and there's always
a different color palette or a different
font or a different size of of your header
and you know i think all of those things kind
of come together um to create an output and so
the the easiest way to um play around with design
is just kind of i i guess like design is mostly
at least for um you know web frameworks it's
just having fun with you know css and javascript
and kind of just diving in um changing around
you know backgrounds or like we started with
very very bold and fluorescent colors and
then we realized well maybe not everyone
likes looking at something so you know intense
and you know how do we make that maybe a bit more
um easy on the eyes i guess and you know how do
we change a color palette to really show what
we're trying to visualize um and so i think all
of those things are super fun to play around with
um and yeah just kind of getting
in there and changing everything
i know you said well you've said already too but
that brooklyn said you want this to be a place of
innovation and that there's been reports that were
more of static texts and pdfs which you're trying
to make cooler um i'm just wondering like is there
an example of a report that you've done that for
internally or what kinds of reports for those
yeah so you know i think that um one of the big
things that griff and i are always on the same
page about was interactivity so how do we increase
someone's ability to really play around with it or
um you know to really understand by kind of seeing
the numbers along the way um and so i think most
of our reports have really been designed around
that um we try to stay away from powerpoint
unless we're presenting something kind of to
the business side we try to stay away from you
know kind of static outputs but that being said
you know with our public reports we still come out
with pdfs that are gorgeous as well um you know so
i think there's there's always that that level of
you're never probably going to get rid of it all
um and not everything can be interactive but um
for the most part we've made most of our outputs
interactive which is is fun you know for me
and um and i think for just the team as a whole
cool thank you i'm scrolling through to make
sure i haven't missed any questions right now
but just want to open up the floor to anybody um
if you want to jump in and ask anything live too
so um in rachel's blurb about you
before um the meeting said you're
going to talk a little bit about writing
a job description for tidy model engineers
i'd love to hear about it i hate writing job
descriptions and i'm writing some right now
yeah no so i um i think even with
you know the way that we approach um
titles or what we're trying to look for it's
it's very much an experiment um i think the
main driving factor of that was we wanted
something different that really would relate
to our community um i think a lot of our code is
in our currently and we're we're constantly trying
to find ways to to kind of increase um i guess
that portion of the business um and so i think
the main driving factor of that role was just
that um we wanted someone that felt that they were
you know really talented with a specific skill to
apply and to be found um and i think that that's
that's always something that you find with data
science right you you post a data science role
and that could mean a billion things and that's
what's always difficult about data sciences
it covers so much that if you don't be or
if you you can't find a way as bad english
if you can't find a way to to be really
specific about what you're looking for
um you're you're probably just going to attract
a lot of people but not as many people that
are focused on what you're
focused on or trying to accomplish
thanks zach um is there a question that
you would like to ask to the audience
i didn't prepare you for that but doing it on here
i think that's um i mean i just be interested like
what everyone does like what they enjoy you
know do you like coding do you not like coding
um all you know anyone that wants
to kind of introduce themselves
on a personal level that would be really cool um
thank you for everyone that has asked questions um
i do have perhaps a related question but i'm
happy to introduce myself as well um my name
is seph i enjoy long walks on the beach um since i
live in southern california um but uh i am i work
for concert ai which is a real world data company
we worked in basically cancer analytics to kind of
sum it up um i i'm i'm curious because i've been a
part of this wonderful little meetup for some time
now um and we talk a lot about like python and r
and those are generally our data science tools but
i'm curious and and this also could be for you
zac but for anybody else is what are people's
thoughts on limiting or minimizing use of both
both languages so let's say you minimize python
or you minimize r and just try to consolidate the
team on one my personal opinion is that there's
technical debt that get that accrues as you more
languages you apply because people obviously are
comfortable in one or the other but i'd love to
hear what other people's thoughts are on that
yeah so i i would be curious to
hear everyone's thoughts as well
um and maybe i'll just kind of quickly
um i think it's it's a great question
and i'd agree that there's there's some level of
the more technologies that you use or the more
um factors that you have in what makes up
you know a data science team um sometimes it
could be hard but i also you know have the
sense that there's a lot of value in both
um or multiple um and the more that you
can find ways to leverage it the better um
but i think it's just a great question so i i'd
be curious if if anyone wants to weigh in as well
i see brian's i'll jump in hi i'm brian butler
i manage a small data science team at banking
um i am a fan of both um in fact my junior
data scientist before he was started with me
he was mostly r and then he converted all the
python and i was doing all python but i'm like
these are tools i i think about a carpenter how
many nail guns they have how many different saws
do they have it's the same thing like if i want
to bang out a quick analysis i'm going to do it
in r i can load the data in i can write two lines
of code and i've got a gg plot that's interactive
and everything else and boom i can solve that
prob that question pretty hard pretty easily
now at the same time as if i'm going to do some
serious natural language processing or some
deep learning i'm going to switch gears but the
best part of it is what i like doing is wrapping
python into our markdown and doing presenting
presenting through these interactive
apps that you can use with you know plotly
and r and everything else and then you wrap
the base model the python around it and um so
i mean i i just think you're not going to be
skilled at every tool you use but
to think the more tools you have
you'll be more effective because you'll
find the right one for the right job
i i think that's a great answer yeah
i see floors and rick are
both unmuted so i take that as
as raising hands maybe if i can jump down there
sure oh sorry
you go ahead floors oh okay hello my name
is jeff florespot i'm from the netherlands
actually first time i joined this group but
i think it's a great question and actually
the same applies here for packages within rf
because you have so many packages you could
restrict yourself that to all kinds of packages
actually i just heard deeply i'm very much fam
in front of data table to be honest but i use them
both and i see that both deliver a lot of value
for us how we use it is is we we just have a
good documentation how to use the packages how to
do your coding so we can
always take over work from
from each other i think the same applies
therefore using python r but even julia or go
if you add it to your your markdown can be
used as long as you just um document it well
i actually love that um yeah i i think that
documentation and having an understanding
of how to use something is is always
something that that's worth solving for
um and yeah i i really like that answer because
like i would love to go into an r markdown and
see like 20 different languages and find ways
to to you know get value out of all of them
that'd just be kind of fun um and so i i
really like that answer yeah just just and
one addition for the whole documentation we use
actually the book down i think it's also from uh
i never can pronounce his name to be honest but
uh but it's amazing yeah so we have many of those
book downs where you just say well like heavily
accurate this is the the r for data science
is really great to do your documentation
for your whole team and we publish it on a
web server easier to to search for all your style
guides for everything you have yeah that's amazing
i like it i i would uh i would also um echo the
sentiment of uh using lots of different tools i
i'm just teaching a data data science full
three-month uh boot camp kind of course at
the moment and we just wrapped up a lot of what's
going to be r and we're going to go on to python
next week and i told the students right from
the outset that we're going to be using both
r and python and i tried to always highlight
why we're doing this in r like we just all the
statistics was an r database was all in r that
imagine was all in our reporting was all in our
and we want to to python we'll be doing the deep
learning and machine learning and things like that
inside of python but i'm not going
to make them do statistics in python
i don't think it's i think it's worthwhile
and i don't think it's nice to do data margin
in python either so they have nice tools to do
that also in in r so i'll show them some of it
but i'm not going to they're not going to be
the same level and all skills in both of them
so i i like the idea of use the tools that
you got and use the diversity that you got
instead of trying to do and us versus them know
you're gonna do everything in this package or
everything in this language and everybody on that
side is wrong kind of uh sentiment i think is
something that i don't try and reflect
in my work and give to my students either
so i like that idea of kind of using all
the resources you have available to you but
when i talk to people on the ground who are not
just training but actually working in in companies
and consulting they say well actually what
really happens is that you can use r but the i t
department is not going to support you in anything
if use python at least they'll take a look at your
scripts and they may give some critique and try
and help you understand what's going wrong so the
support that they get from other departments of
the company also determines what they're actually
going to use in the end so there's that practical
component that is not as idealistic i think
no i i i think that that's that's accurate um i
think at the end of the day that that kind of gets
back to sometimes you have systems and that's what
you got to use even if there's a better solution
um and so i think that's always you know on the
table or part of it um and i think the only way
that you can get kind of people to convert or to
see your side of it is just to create something
cool um i think at least that's worked for me is
if you can show someone something cool then it's
it's kind of easier to say yeah this is why i use
this or um yeah and so i i guess like that's the
it's always part of the game um and i
find that the more you can make it fun or
interesting is always the easiest way
thanks for all of that if everybody um can i add
context to this question yeah is that okay i was
gonna say thank you for asking that question
and seemed to fire everyone up yeah i know i
should have asked it way sooner i apologize um so
the the and i this is great so i don't disagree
with everybody i think that obviously all of these
tools have a place in everything so well sometimes
python especially from a data engineering
perspective that's what people are using for
for ingestion for etl and so it's really helpful
to have that tool set and generally you'll always
have that tool set and for r for its variety of
purposes what's interesting is what i see from
like an industry perspective is that there's also
a component that technical debt that you accrue
when people are using multiple languages is that
there are systems that need to support those
languages right so as rick pointed sometimes it's
python and that's what they're supporting right
sometimes it's r sometimes it's both but when you
have more systems or languages you need to support
there's more libraries there's more whatever
all of that plays a technical debt on whatever
the it system whatever the platform system so
generally you don't want to have 20 languages
you want to limit it and so python r is fine but
there's also a technical debt towards expertise
towards like if i'm if i only know how to do it
in sql and i only do it in sql but another team
is doing it in python and another team is doing
it in our right you now have three different ways
that you're approaching perhaps the same problem
and people only want to then deal with it in the
language that they're most familiar with and so
from a broader perspective when you're trying
to scale like it might be helpful to say look i
know you i know you know how to do it in sql but
learning it in r or doing it in python or whatever
the choice would be may have value for the company
as it scales because once that person leaves or if
they go on vacation or something someone else can
then pick it up and then i think flores
said documenting it appropriately is
is great and i 100 agree but i guess that's just
the context behind the question i'm not trying to
say that we should pick one language or another
but um i guess you know maybe if i can jump in
on one quick comment about that one of the
things that um i noticed we were writing
the book this past year the r in python for modern
data science and we kind of almost had a hard time
finding nice use cases and i got some
examples from colleagues on twitter
but i realized that um you know we organized the
book in terms of you choose our python dependent
on the type of data that you're working on so if
it's time series or unstructured or geospatial
there there's different um package ecosystems
that are well suited in each of the languages
and some of them are better than others
um like spacey is fantastic for nlp
i wouldn't necessarily recommend although there's
fantastic things for nlp in r but space is really
kind of dominating that scene in um in python and
so we kind of said you know think about the data
structure um the format of the data and the kind
of research problem that you you're dealing with
and then in the in the case study we were
kind of struggling to find a really nice
flow uh like really nice example and we got
something really nice at the end i think but
um it also occurred to me that one of the reasons
people end up using r python that i see actually
in reality with my students that are working in
research is that they come into a laboratory and
they inherit a really terrible python script that
they cannot make heads or tails out of it but the
thing works and there's no reason to reinvent the
wheel but they want to wrap it in r because they
can modify and do things with it and expand it
in r so instead of learning and these are like
crazy long and super complicated scripts that i i
guarantee are much much easier in r but they don't
have the time to translate that all to r so they
stick with it and then they just kind of have to
deal with a python script so i think sometimes
people use rn python not because idealistic
reasons not because they don't want to but
because they just they're stuck with it like they
they have to use this python script or this
r script because somebody wrote it and dumped
on their shoulders 100 that's accurate yeah and i
um i i was just gonna say you know i i think it's
a it's a super interesting question because it's
it's super applicable and at every step of scale
that complexity or that ease has to be kind
of addressed and so it's it's almost like
we know that that's a topic we know
that people are going to use both
how do we really prepare for that or address
it and i think like our studio probably has
the best you know answer for it but um where
they're working on it um one of the two but um
you know i think that it's it's certainly possible
that you're building without that full circle
you know view of it right like um i know that
there's a lot of people developing python that
i i don't know or and probably vice versa um and
so yeah it's it's hard to have kind of a perfect
solution for all of it but i think it's an
interesting question one thing except that i
found really useful was that i have not restricted
languages on my teams and i'd see certain people
because of their backgrounds they were either more
comfortable with one or the other which was nice
because they're um it allowed for a lot of cross
training but then if people were unsure about a
problem there were even more ways to try to come
to an answer and understanding from a different
approach whether it python or r or different
packages was really good and thought provoking and
found more errors and got better answers in
the end there is definitely stress from having
more languages but i think it's worth it i like
that yeah and i think like um but the one thing
that you just said was you know there's
almost some stress from that and i think
um i think sep asked an earlier question about you
know how do people stay up to date on languages
and so i think that that's that's one of the hard
things as well is like if if you're constantly
doing something other than that how do you stay
up to date on what's going on or what's important
um but i love that there's multiple ways to answer
that and like it offers more capabilities to
do that because that's that's really really
valuable and so i think that that's awesome
uh yeah all good conversation hi this is bala i
just want to add one thing said so right now if
you restrict so both python and r uh right now has
so much maturity and it's it's open source right a
lot of packages are being you know contributed for
most of the standard use cases you get packages
which are wrapper around the package which is done
in python so if there is a species package for nlp
in python there is a spacey r which is a wrapper
which basically runs the same package in the r
environment so if it is a generic use case which
you know is being used across multiple industries
then you really don't have that problem like oh
my developer have it's much easier to migrate
because the speed to market is what you as as a
data scientist you you would like as a data team
you would like to do so a problem is given you
want to solve it as quicker as possible and if
if you're taking or if you're adding red tape
saying like oh you can't use python or you can't
use r you're naturally you know creating blockhead
so i would say you should allow your team to
explore in whichever language
which is comfortable for them
but again when they design just think about
like are there wrappers can i integrate you know
whatever i've done so that it is future proof
just in case yeah and to be clear i don't
have any restrictions i thought i thought
it was an interesting thought experiment
before everyone spears me and
cancels me or whatever but uh but yes
thank you i'd love for you to introduce your cat
as well over i add one there thing and then i'm
completely i agree with you guys so and then you
need to restrict it on your technical debt it's
difficult to keep everything up and running just
also for a decade there we had a very specific use
case where we have actually needed to use python
there was a package in nr in 3.6 to connect to the
sap systems and to extract data that one was
not maintained anymore by the maintainer from
australia sap is maintaining a python package so
now we are using a python package and to get the
stuff in our use reticulat to get it in in in
our and manipulate it in oregon so now we have
to have them both but we have a very strict
distinction between the functionality one is
is importing the data the other one is building
your model and creating your uh visualizations
i like that it's really nice example you
can't you but you kind of got stuck with it
and this is her name is excel actually i'm
kidding no her name is zoe her name is zoe
bruno said bring all the cats next week
well thank you all so much for a lively
discussion i just want to make sure i
didn't cut off any final questions there
you know we're a little bit over but um thank you
so much for for joining today and zach thanks so
much for for sharing your insights with the group
um just quick question for you zach if people have
follow-up questions where is the best way to get
in touch with you linkedin or twitter what do you
prefer yeah no linkedin works great um and thanks
so much for for all the fun um i had a lot of fun
so uh thanks for spending some time with me and
and thank you so much for organizing thank you
appreciate it and i know i haven't been saying
this lately like who are the next speakers
and i don't mean to be keeping it a secret
um so same time same place next week um
we'll be joined by kobe abayomi who's a face vice
president of data science at warner music group
as well so thank you all for joining
and hope to see you next week too
you